- Hi everybody, I'm Maurice Samuels
the Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to the final installment for this semester
in our special Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker Lecture Series,
dedicated to exploring the connections
between antisemitism and other forms
of racism and prejudice.
Today, we're especially
fortunate to have with us
Terrence L. Johnson.
Terrence is Associate Professor
of Religion and Politics
in the Department of Government
at Georgetown University,
where he's also an
affiliate faculty member
of the Department of
African-American studies
and senior faculty fellow
at the Berkeley Center
for Religion, Peace and World Affairs.
His research interests
include African-American
political thought,
American religion and
public life and ethics.
He's the author
of, "We Testify with
Our Lives: How Religion
Transformed Radical
Thought from Black Power
to Black Lives Matter",
which is about to be published
by Columbia University Press. in 2021.
He's also the co-author of the forthcoming
"Blacks and Jews: An
Introduction to a Dialogue"
which is gonna be published by
Georgetown University Press.
also in 2021.
He's also the author of "Tragic
Soul-Life: W. E. B. Du Bois
"and the Moral Crisis
Facing American Democracy"
published by Oxford in 2012.
His essays have appeared in a number
of edited volumes and journals,
including the "Journal
of Religious Ethics",
"Journal of Africana
Religions", "Cross Occurrence"
and the "Journal of the
Society of Christian Ethics".
Johnson is also the co-editor
of "The Religious Cultures
of African and African
Diaspora", people book series,
which is published by
Duke University Press.
Now, the way it'll work today
is that Terrence will
speak for about 30 minutes
and then we'll have the
chance to ask him questions
for another 30 minutes.
So please submit your questions anytime
using the Q&A function at
the bottom of the screen.
So you're welcome to submit
the questions during the talk
and I will filter,
I'll ask him the questions
that you submit to me
during the talk and after.
I won't be seeing raised
hand and we won't be using
the Chat function.
So please only use the Q&A.
So the title of Terrence's talk today
is Grounds for Hope: Blacks, Jews,
and the Future of Democracy.
Please join me in silently
welcoming Terence L Johnson.
- Great, thank you so much,
Professor Maurice Samuels,
it's an honor to be here.
I'd like to thank the
Yale Program for the Study
of Antisemitism for this opportunity
to show our work on Blacks and Jews
and a special thank you to Inessa Laskova
for managing the minor and major details
of this Zoom discussion.
So, I come today really with, I would say
a slightly heavy heart.
In part, because when I
initially started teaching
this course on Blacks and Jews in America,
with two colleagues at
Haverford College back in 2009,
it was really more of
a kind of intellectual
sort of theoretical pursuit
to explore how history,
religion, ethics sort
of overlap and overlap
with this particular set of individuals
or ethnic groups within the US.
But something changed
after Trump's election
and with the Charlottesville
protests in 2016.
And as we sort of think about this moment
in terms of what changed
for me intellectually
and personally, I would
like to just have a moment
of silence to remember
those who were murdered
at Mother Emanuel AME Church in 2015
and the Tree of Life Synagogue in 2018,
both groups were murdered
because they were black
or because they were Jewish.
Tywanza Sanders, Reverend
Sharonda Coleman Singleton,
Reverend Clementa Pinckney,
Cynthia Hurd, Myra Thompson,
Reverend DePayne Middleton Doctor,
Susie Jackson, Ethel Lance,
Reverend Daniel Simmons,
Joyce Fienberg, Richard Gottfried,
Rose Mallinger, Jerry Rabinowitz,
Cecil Rosenthal, David Rosenthal,
Bernice Simon, Sylvan Simon, Daniel Stein,
Melvin Wax and Irving Younger.
And how do we get here?
When I first heard
of the Unite to Right
Rally in Charlottesville,
I assumed it would be
close to characters,
protesting immigration,
those, you know,
illegally entering the borders
or something to do with gay marriage.
This idea that, you know,
liberals are taking over democracy,
but I was shocked, right?
When I discovered that at
the very heart of the rally
was about anti-blackness and antisemitism.
And as my colleague, Jack
Butler Bali talked this over
after we watched this horrific clip,
we were stunned by what we discovered.
And I wanna take us back to that moment.
So someone more capable like Donald Trump,
who does not
give his daughter to the Jew.
So when we think about
blacks and Jews in America,
often this iconic picture
emerges in our mind,
right, of Rabbi Abraham Heschel and King
walking arm and arm in Selma in 1963.
And we think of the whole idea
of a grand alliance, right?
This idea of blacks and
Jews fighting arm and arm
against social unrest,
fighting against anti-black
racism, antisemitism.
And we think of a very harmonious group.
And then we think of a big
explosion happening in 67
with the emergence of Israel
and this whole idea of black power
invoking black independence,
and then really in some
ways, frightening Jews
and pushing many of the
Jewish members of Snake
out of the organization
to build a kind of, sort
of self-reliant group.
And that is sort of the
kind of the narrative
we often hear about.
But I wanna argue that the
story is far more complicated.
And while we're not going
to all the details side,
I wanna argue that it's completed in part,
because someone like
Adolf Reed is gonna argue
that there are many different
types of relationship
between blacks and Jews.
We have elite blacks and
Jews working hand in hand,
right, at the turn of the
20th century with the founding
of NACP and also blacks and Jews working
with the Urban League, right?
And these are African-Americans
and Jews who are, you know,
a part of, sort of the
establishment as it were.
And if not a part of the establishment
that definitely on the trajectory, right,
of a middle-class sort of
ideology really thinking through
how do we work together, right,
to solidify our rights as citizens,
but also how do we work
together to end segregation
and antisemitism and
all the barriers right,
to achieving the so-called American Dream.
'Cause that's one aspect of this story.
The other aspect of the
story really has to do with,
you know, day workers, right?
And sort of, you know,
Jewish merchants who are
often engaged in businesses,
you know, because of
segregation at the time
permanently were forced to
work in black communities.
And so there's another relationship
between Jewish merchants
and say African-American
working class individuals.
And also African-American
women who are day workers
working within Jewish homes.
So we have these sort of two
tiered kinds of relationships.
And so part of what I'm trying to do
in part as a result of
Charlottesville is sort of re-think
why is this material important to me?
And part of why I think it's important
is because I think
there's something in terms
within the kind of the infighting
within the sort of the
solidarity movements
between the groups
that we can actually
glean to help us think
about public deliberation,
to help us really re-think
what is political solidarity
and also help us to re-think
what are the grounds
for understanding religion
and sort of cross religious
sort of dialogue.
And so I wanna put forth an argument
that is really developed,
or at least started by Eric Sundquist
and argue that part of
the issue is this idea
that the Exodus right,
is binding African-Americans
and Jews to the sort of really
ancient kind of history.
And as many of you might recall an Exodus
it's like this notion
that "Thus says the Lord,
"The God of Israel, let my people go,
"That they may celebrate a feast to me."
And so this becomes a
kind of gathering call
for both groups, sort of
to really think through
the promise of Yahweh, the promise of God.
And I wanna argue that this
kind of relationship, right,
linking together blacks and
Jews through the Exodus story,
not the Holocaust or
black suffering in death
creates the possibility, right,
for thinking through texts as
lived possibilities, right,
texts as something that's live, not dead,
but also really to help
us think through the ways
in which disparate groups, right,
can actually bracket immediate
social circumstances,
immediate economic circumstances,
and really try to link
to kind of a narrative
that is constant but shifting.
In other words,
I wanna argue that blacks and Jews, right,
have within their fingertips,
this notion of Exodus.
And if we read it in a
kind of a critical lens
through a kind of black
feminist, sort of a woman's
sort of perspective, right,
taking into account Eric
Sundqust's criticisms
of the Exodus narrative as
potentially an imperialistic,
but also taking into account
John Levinson's account
that well maybe the Exodus story
really isn't about a
radicalization of the people.
Maybe it really is about how people
become de-radicalized, right.
I wanna argue that what
if we use this Exodus
as a way of thinking about
what does it mean to exist
in the wilderness?
And what does it mean to exist as a people
who are dispossessed
and who are displaced?
And if we think about it
in these terms, right,
we're shifting the bait
away from this idea
of who's actually a chosen people, right?
We bracket that and we'll
be focused on this idea
of what, how do we gain material freedom
for all human beings?
Because I think if we look
at particularly the works
of King and how King uses Exodus,
as well as Rabbi Abraham Heschel,
we see how the Exodus
becomes a kind of grounding
for live religion and in
live kind of expression
that really changes how we look at texts
and how we look at doctrine
and increase the possibilities
for looking at narrative
as something that is expansive
and a way of welcoming in
rather than using narratives
to foreclose the very
possibility of a mutual dialogue.
You know, Abraham Heschel
was at a conference
and spoke of the ways in
which religion, right?
And race work hand in hand.
And he argued at a conference
religion and race in 1963
that, you know, what Pharaoh was not dead.
And part of the issue that we're facing,
particularly as American Jews,
but also white Protestants
that we have assumed
that Pharaoh is dead
and that the work of
the Exodus is complete.
And if we look at what's
happening to the Negro in America,
you know, during the early and late 1960s,
we see this sort of resurfacing, right,
of a certain kind of evil
Abraham Heschel talks about,
which is racism.
And that when we, as religious
people do not respond
to racism as a legitimate evil,
as something we much work against,
we are turning our back to God, right?
And this then takes us
back to this whole idea
of the Exodus.
And he wants to argue that, you know,
when we think about religion
and race, where he says,
"Look, you can't worship God
"And assume that the
Negro is the problem."
That the Negro is the
aberration of what it means
to be human.
And so he really wants to
use like religion and race
in a very interesting way
that I think really beckons us
to really challenge the very grounds
of American origin stories, right?
Because many of us have been
taught that "Look, the nation
"Is one of, you know, built
upon a city of a Hill."
Think of John went through.
And that from that we get this idea
of American Jeremiad story and
of American exceptionalism.
But what Heschel is pointing
to really are the ways
in which we've used religion, right?
Within a US context,
in many respects to sort
of reify anti-blackness.
And I would even argue antisemitism,
if we go back to James Baldwins article
in the "New York Times"
that blacks are not
antisemitic, they're anti-white.
And so part of what Baldwin
is saying that I think
that Heschel is implicitly
aligning himself with is this
idea that we have not dealt
with the sort of lingering effects
of Christianity's ongoing,
but shifting uses of antisemitic tropes
and of anti-blackness.
And until we begin to deal
with what's at the very core
of the American enterprise,
both Heschel and Baldwin argue
that we're missing the point.
And so, I want us to sort of
think about this whole notion
of we did by anti-Semitism,
we have to also think
about anti-black racism.
And we think about sort of like racism
we have think about antisemitism and look
at the sort of the core origins
of both forms of hatred and
show how in many respects
what connects blacks and Jews
is not the sort of mythic
history of, you know,
we all have gotten along
and we all believe in the same things,
but it's this idea of we
both have a kind of common
sort of oppression around
the ways in which our bodies,
right, for the policies and
this idea that Whoa, well,
Jews are dirty.
So therefore they should
handle dirty money, right.
For white supremacy in the modern context,
this idea that, you know,
blacks are barbarians.
So on the first level,
that then becomes a way
of connecting this idea
that both have experienced to
kind of anti-humanist, right.
From, you know, Christian sort of tropes
and Christian writers.
But then I think if we stay at
that level in terms of let's
like, look at our shared
oppression, right,
then it gets really complicated
because (Terrence sighing)
we begin then to compete
in terms of, well, who's
actually suffering more?
You know, this idea, well,
whose Holocaust is greater?
Is it slavery? Or is it the Holocaust?
And I wanna argue that,
well, let's actually maintain
this notion of the kind
of shared oppression,
but let's not use it as
the kind of foundation
of other relationship.
Let's actually then extend
it to look at how then might
the Exodus, right, as this
idea of dispossessed people,
this idea of a people
who are landless, right.
People who are seeking a certain promise,
how does that then really
re-think what it means,
for us to think about political solidarity
within the US context.
So I think this is important then
also, because it really allows us then
the kind of theoretical
tools to, I think, engage
in modern society,
but also to engage what
Michelle Moody Adams calls,
What is Familiar, right?
Often when we are sort of
debating about injustice, right?
Antisemitism, sexism, transphobia.
We often start from what is very familiar.
And I'm not saying that's
a bad starting point,
but I think we can't end there.
And so part of what
invoking excess narrative
allows us to do,
I think is to bring in a
new set of sort of tools
to think through the very
grounds upon which we
are exerting, right?
Our sense of outrage about injustice.
And so, part of what is
linking then King and Heschel
is this idea of really
breaking the silence, right?
King argues that, "Silence
is a form of betrayal".
And so, let's go back then
to what lessons can we learn
from how African Americans
have used this Exodus story
and how I'm trying to bring it together.
One would argue that African
Americans have really viewed
the Bible historically as
a kind of talking book.
There's an actual story in
archives of a slave who witnessed
a slave master reading this book.
And he said, he literally
saw the book talking.
Henry Louis Gates talks about this
in his work "Signifying Monkey".
And from that moment on
the slave went to the
Bible and wanted the Bible
to talk back.
And so this became a kind of
trope with an African American
sort of religious folklore.
And so when American
slaveholders told this story
of the Exodus to the slaves,
and connected to this idea
that you know of Paul's notion
that well, your inheritance
is really in heaven.
So don't see the story
as liberating you now,
but I actually liberates
you in the future.
It's interesting the slaves,
we actually reject that story.
We reject that interpretation
and we want to read the story
as an example of what God can
do for one group of people
is a reminder of what God can do for us.
And so it became a way in
which they turn to the Bible
as a kind of talking book
as this kind of form of engagement.
And this thing created a
sense of radical hermeneutics.
And that scripture became
a kind of living texts.
And this is important, I think,
because it will force
us to really re-think
both blacks and Jews
in terms of what are we holding as sacred
that both binds us to our tradition
and to what is sacred.
And that those things are also necessary.
But then how then do we allow
for the very possibility
of rupturing that which we hold is sacred?
I think part of the answer
and the tools for this is
thinking about how slave
saw scripture as a kind of living text.
And then next is idea, as
I mentioned before then,
as a living text,
the slaves embrace Exodus
story as a kind of narrative
of God's promise for the future
and to use this as a guide,
to think through the New Testament
and to think through their
own sort of material history
in terms of enslaved people.
So then, from this notion, they
began to build a tradition.
And this tradition
includes the Sorrow Songs,
W.E.B. Du Bois talks
about this idea of really
the nation's first sort of, you know,
music that breathe life into the nation,
but also spoke of the life of slaves.
And clearly then we have
the Fisk Jubilee Singers
and then Aretha Franklin.
And so I wanna connect this
to a really interesting kind
of story in terms of how
we think about again,
texts as living and it's kind
of dialogical engagement.
And there's a famous song by
that at Aretha Franklin,
it's called " Oh Mary, Don't You Weep".
And it's a song that sort of
links God's liberating hand
in the New Testament to Pharaoh's defeat.
And what's also interesting
is that the songwriter
and the earliest slaves sort
of weave together, right?
Both the Exodus story along
with the New Testament
to really kind of create
this interesting exchange
that links together both traditions,
but then creates the possibility
for something new to emerge.
And again, I think it
beckons to this whole idea
that when blacks and Jews are working,
whether it's at the elite level
or even at this kind of
working class exchange,
there's a constant kind of navigation.
And part of that navigation,
at least on the part of African Americans
has everything to do with this idea
of seeing the texts and
looking at texts in general,
as a kind of talking book
and how this talking book
creates a kind of dialogical exchange.
So I wanna read part of the lyrics to you
and then play an excerpt
from Aretha Franklin.
It's not like a whole idea.
Oh, Mary don't you weep don't you moan
Pharaoh's army got drowned in the red sea,
Oh Mary don't you weep.
If I could surely would,
I'd stand on the rock
where Moses did
Pharaoh's army got drowned,
Oh, Mary don't weep.
Oh, Mary don't you weep,
tell Martha don't you moan, listen, Mary.
And it's a story in terms
of what happens with Lazarus
and the re-birth and there were Lazarus.
I wanna just play a
quick excerpt of the song
to kind of invoke, right,
this kind of exchange of the
singer and their audience,
how this speaks to this living tradition.
And so part of what I want to show,
we thinking through so to music, right.
And that sort of exchanges
that will we hear in terms
of the sort of lead singer and the choir,
and so the musicians is right,
this sort of constant exchanging
in terms of who has primary
leadership role, right?
This idea of trying to re-narrate a story
around the promise, right.
That people see within sacred texts.
And I think this in many
respects speaks to the ways
in which blacks and Jews,
I think at the core, right,
despite the kind of infighting
and the frustrations, right.
They have the core, they are
sort of navigating, right,
a set of texts to help them
think through how to make sense
of the material world,
but in a way that I think if
we keep those sort of Exodus
as a kind of living ongoing sort of story,
that isn't dead,
I think really speaks to the
ways in which freedom can be
fully sort of embodied.
And so, you know, Eric goes
and reminds us this idea
that, you know, that it's
extending from Rabbi Heschel,
that Exodus is far from being completed.
And so, as we look at
say the role or the rise
of American Jews during the new deal
and with sort of the rise of
Jews as they left inner cities
in the late forties and fifties,
and moved to the suburbs
and were embraced by,
you know, white Gentiles,
there is on the one
hand, a story of, well,
clearly Jews are kind of model minority.
They are very successful.
And so therefore they
don't experience, you know,
the kinds of bigotry
that African-Americans have experienced.
And I wanna join with
Eric Goldstein and argue
that what's interesting is
that even with this kind
of sort of professional success, right,
among many American Jews,
what he wants to remind us
is that this idea that Jews
we have remained a kind of other.
Well, they may not have been marginalized
from the sort of the structures of power.
They remain a constant other,
which creates his own kind of
double consciousness, right.
And what we see with the
rise of Charlottesville
is that that otherness
is sort of materialized in
a kind of unspoken hatred
and unspoken antisemitism that seems
to surface every few decades,
especially when we're
experiencing some form of economic
or political trauma.
And then, I wanna link
that in terms of, well,
what is otherness?
How does that link to African-Americans?
What links us to idea,
what Dubois call really the Negro problem?
And so idea that in the
American context, right?
Blacks have been defined
as a legitimate ontological problem.
And the nation has been
working desperate to figure out
how do we solve this problem?
And that has been actually the source
of what sort of reifies
anti-blackness is that people assume
blacks are the problem.
And so what becomes interesting,
right, is that, you know,
despite the kinds of
differences in terms of economic
and political success
between blacks and Jews,
there remains is kind of tension, right?
There's kind of social tension around Jews
as a kind of perennial other
and blacks as the kind of
perennially marginalized people.
And so, as we think about the ways
in which this marginalization
and otherness emerges,
I wanna argue and again, this
is a work that is developing
that we have to re-think Israel
in the role of Africa, right,
in our respective communities.
And I wanna join in with V.Y.
Mudimbe of Duke University
and argue that we have invented
right, sacred places, right.
As a way to affirm what is
familiar as a way to protect us
against white supremacy, right.
As a way to legitimate
who we are as peoples
to affirm our forms of civilization.
But I think in doing so, right,
we have not explore through to
the dangers of what it means
then to create these sacred
places that then we then lack
in a moment in history that
we lack as sort of a model
for protecting us
against a kind of
suffering a kind of death.
And I think as long as we
keep these places right,
as a kind of trope or source
for protection, right,
we will not be able to see the
possibilities of how they can
open up new possibilities for who we are.
And I think we'll continue to have right,
the Palestinian problem.
So moonless large interface,
when also Africa we'll see right.
The continued problems
around poverty, right.
And around leadership.
And so what does it mean then?
How is Israel reinvented in
our lives and how's Africa
reinvented into our lives?
And so I made this, I'll
discuss this a bit later
because we're running out of time here,
but I want to bring in
sort of the rapper Drake
to kind of think through for us,
what does it mean to kind
of think about reinvention
of not only of who we are
as a sacred people, right.
But reinvention, reinventing
the Exodus, right.
As a way to call those beyond our sort
of racial constructions and
to call us for what phenomenal
call it kind of new humanism.
And let me go here one second.
So as we prepare to sort of think through,
so the grounds of hope,
one of the reasons why I wanted
to sort of end with Drake
is in part to try to invoke the ways
in which reinvention
right, happens all the time
and this idea of rethinking Exodus, right.
I think it's actually necessary
because I don't imagine
a kind of quote grand
Alliance happening again.
I think the economic
disparities are too great.
I think for most of my students,
both white and white Jews
and African-Americans,
they have no personal interactions.
They don't live in the same neighborhoods
they don't go to the same
sort of social functions.
They may work together, but
they don't have an intimacy.
But I think if we can focus on
sort of the sacred texts, right.
And use them as kind of these
sort of discursive sites
for re-exploring the
ways in which we continue
to spread our wealth, or
despite our lack of wealth,
continue to face a kind
of dispossession, right.
Kind of landlessness,
as it were kind of wilderness experience,
I think it opens the possibility then
for using this history, not
necessarily regain an Alliance,
if it happens, it would be great,
but to find useful ways
within our different communities, right.
To fight against racism,
transphobia, right.
The issues that are so did they
keep from becoming the full
humans that Rabbi Heschel
talked about and again,
there are lots of, kind of,
I would say pitfalls here.
I mean, lots of, sort of
histories that are repulsive
on both parts, and we can go through that
during the discussion, but I
want to focus on given the ways
in which, you know,
we see this resurgence of white supremacy,
this resurgence of
anti-Semitism anti-blackness
I want to figure out how then
do we look at sort of the past
as a way of remembering
the kind of Toni Morrison's
way of cultivating, right.
We have dismantling, repairing
and re-imagining possibilities.
I think the Exodus right,
is the one story that sort of links us,
but still recognizes our deep differences.
So thank you very much for attending.
And I look forward to
hearing your questions.
- Thank you Terrence, for
that really thought provoking
and very entertaining, I
have to say presentation.
And it just made me think that, you know,
at the anti-Semitism program,
we don't actually have many
religious studies scholars
talking and it's such like an important,
different way of thinking, you know,
we mostly have historians
political scientists.
And so I thought it was
just very stimulating
to have actually that way
of thinking presented to us
to think about, you know,
such an important issue.
So a lot of questions.
So let's just kind of dive in.
One question I had is,
you know, I can't help,
but think that one of the
obstacles to a kind of black
Jewish dialogue in America
comes from a contrast in the way
the two groups think about,
or kind of represent to
themselves, their story in America.
So, you know, for black people, obviously,
slavery is looming, you
know, extremely large,
and this kind of, America connotes,
oppression to a large extent,
whereas for Jews, I think they tend to see
their history in America,
as you know, itself,
an Exodus and a kind of
liberation, you know,
to a problematic extent.
I just came from another
talk earlier today
about the history of
anti-Semitism in America
that I think Jews have a hard time
even facing up to themselves.
I think there's a kind
of tendency within Jewish
historiography, but also
popular Jewish culture
to see America really,
as the promised land
and to kind of whitewash
all the different ways
in which it was not always
the case that America
was so open to Jews, to the extent
what happened in Charlottesville
came as a total shock,
you know, and of course in Pittsburgh too.
So I'm wondering if you can
address those two contrasting
narratives of what America means.
- No, Maurice that's a great question.
And there's so many ways to answer it.
I think, you know, what's
interesting that I think about
Michael stops 20 at the roots, right?
This idea that for many
earliest Jewish families
was this whole idea when
we come to America, right,
you stay below the radar, you
recognize the opportunities,
but you also recognize sort
of the imminence of death.
And what's also interesting
for African-Americans
turns that issue around slavery, right?
It's really not until the
late 80s when Morrison
introduces beloved that
African-Americans are be,
are publicly talking about slavery.
I mean, she argues that
she wrote the book in part
because black folk had buried the history
and didn't want anything to do with it
because it was a public sort of mark
of their inferiority right.
Of how they'd been captive in
a kind of a horrible history.
And so when beloved comes
out, I think Wendy's Eyelea
really talks about this whole idea.
Well, wait and are you trying
to create a new Holocaust moment?
Because again, beloved comes out as we see
the emergence of the
American Holocaust museum,
and people are finally
talking about the Holocaust
in America sort of role in
that, or a lack of sort of,
you know, stand up next to during the war
and for African-Americans it was like,
Oh, this is what American Jews are doing.
Let us now then begin
to talk about slavery
and very interesting.
And it's kind of a similar way.
And then there's another moment
sort of prior to that in
1960s, where Eric Sundquist,
is gonna argue that what
black power in some respects
allows Jews to say, wait a minute,
I can also claim a kind
of self identity, right.
In my Jewish incident,
my Zionist sort of background
as a way to exert myself.
So some Rabbis, particularly
in the Midwest region
are saying, and I'm sorry,
Midwest in terms of mid
Atlantic region rather
are using the black power
as a way to try to ignite
a kind of, sort of public
remembering of Jewish
life in America.
And as you say to stop
whitewashing that history.
So I do think so it's a kind
of a complicated history.
So I think on the one hand,
both groups publicly are masking
how they are internalizing
and responding to white supremacy.
And I think we do in a mascot
for different reasons, right?
I think for African-Americans
is a site of shame.
Like they, you know,
they are trying to show
through the politics
of respectability and
racial ideology and look,
that we too can pull us
up by our bootstraps.
And for American Jews is
a recognition that, well,
I'm not white and I'm
discriminated against
at the same time, right.
I recognize what's happening
to African-Americans,
but I also don't want, particularly
for Southern Jews, right?
Many of them were merchant owners.
I don't want to get killed.
So there was a kind of
strange kind of silence,
but yet recognition
that I too am like them.
So I think it's a really
kind of complicated history,
but both are responding to a
kind of anti-ice, anti-Semitism
kind of type blackness and both,
I kind of have this lingering
sense of death that's eminent.
- Really interesting, okay.
So here's a question from
a real expert on the topic,
Cheryl Greenberg.
- Oh my god, hello.
Oh my gosh, Cheryl Greenberg
it's great to see you.
Or have your question here.
- Yeah, so she says, this is
fascinating and persuasive,
but how do we make sense of
the fact that most of the Jews
who were most involved with civil rights
were the least religious.
So reform leftist non-religious Jews,
the Orthodox by contrast were
nowhere to be seen focusing on
religious obligations or
approaches did not seem to tie
into Jewish engagement in the movement
and the black Jewish women in the past.
So how might it now, especially
with more Jews than others
identifying with secular.
- Wow, that's a great question of course,
by the great scholar, thank you so much.
I think you're right.
And what I've been trying to
figure out is what role then,
how does her Abraham Heschel,
so play sort of writ large right within,
so the Jewish community.
And I do think we see in
terms of, at least in DC,
some of the conservative Rabbis
are actually speaking out
in favor, right.
In sermons and maybe
they're not present in body,
but some of their sermons indicating
that they're recognizing what's happening
to African-Americans in the 60s,
and there's a kind of willingness
at least to articulate it,
that sort of concern within their sermons.
Now I think you're right
in terms of the South
is a very different kind of story, right?
There's a sense in which very real threat,
other fear of their death.
And so what does it mean for this moment?
Well, I know the New York Times
had this great sort of
picture of acidic Jews
who held the signs of Black Lives Matter.
And I think what you are
at a different moment
now where conservative Jews in
particular recognizing right
sort of the limits of sort
of the benefits of whiteness,
right, because of this kind of othering.
And I do think when we look
at what happened in Ferguson,
in Missouri, that a number
of conservative Jews
were on the ground at, you know,
our Rabbi at Georgetown gave me
great anecdotal stories about this.
So I think, but the problem is,
I think there's a different problem.
I think we're seeing more of
the quote leadership right
within the Jewish community,
on the grounds of Black Lives Matter.
And conversely, we're
seeing less leadership
in the black community
with Black Lives Matter
more in terms of the youth wellness.
So, I think we've gotta figure out how do
we make these bridges?
And I'm actually later
today, later this evening,
speaking to the Hebrew congregation in DC,
my colleague and I and
Jack are gonna talk through
some of these issues, but I
think now they should becomes,
well, how do we like
transfer this information?
Or sort of the activism
from sort of the leadership,
the Rabbis to the actual
sort of congregation.
And that becomes a hard part
because my colleague Jack says,
it's this whole idea of how do you reckon
with this sort of history, right?
Rabbi Stein Law, who was the Rabbi
at the conservative Israel here in DC
where the late Ruth Ginsburg
attended had this great sermon
a couple of years ago on, you know,
Jews have to recognize they're not white
and return to Judaism.
And again, for people who are not really,
there's this whole sense
of, wait, are you saying,
I need to become more religious
in order to have this sort
of social justice sort of
Ethel's and an activism.
And he's like, yes,
because you're are Jews
and you have to recognize
that's why you're here.
So, and I have a problem with in part,
because it speaks to the idea, well,
there's a kind of burden then being chosen
that, and are you saying then that Jews
have more responsibility right.
To advocate for anti-bullying
or to fight against
anti-blackness because of right.
This weight of being what
it means to be Jewish,
according to this
particular kind of belief.
So I hope that I know is scratches
to your question, Cheryl,
but I'm still thinking
through, but thank you.
I think it was a great question.
- Yeah, I mean, it's such
an interesting question.
The question of Orthodox
Jews, because, you know,
as you said, you know, there
used to be much more contact,
I think between blacks and Jews.
And now it's really Orthodox
Jews in certain neighborhoods
in Brooklyn who have the
most day-to-day contact.
And it's such an
interesting thought, like,
would they be more receptive
to a religious, you know,
approach to dialogue or less, you know,
it would be really interesting
to know how they would,
you know, hear what you're
saying about Exodus anyway.
So one other question I had is whether
you can trace historically
some of the kind of decline of
dialogue to changes within
the black church in general,
you know, over the last,
let's say 30 years.
So, and maybe, you know,
do you see a kind of,
is the black church playing
a kind of less of a role now
in shaping and, you
know, promoting dialogue?
What do you think?
- Well, that's a great question.
I mean, when I, as I'm
getting calls, anecdotally,
I'm finding that it's real,
I'm getting calls from
Jewish communities and Jewish
community leaders who want
to talk with this issue.
And when I talked to colleagues and peers
who are African-Americans are like, well,
why are we having this?
Why do you want to talk
about blacks and Jews?
You know, they're white,
there's no connection, right?
They're successful, we're not.
And so it's this interesting
kind of shift in terms
of the conversation.
I think in part of it has
to do, I think with, again,
I'm not trying to blame it on a boogeyman,
but the ways in which
social structures, right?
Forced, I mean, in many cases,
forced Jews out of urban areas, right.
We have the case in Boston
where literally bankers
and legislator says, look, we
want to reclaim back Bay area,
which is mostly African-American.
And we wanna actually moved into Roxbury.
Well, that's where most
of the Jews were living.
It was like, okay, well,
we're going to basically
go and tell Jews, look,
the blacks are coming, they're
going to rape your women.
And you're probably valuing and go down,
you better get out of here.
And so some people are like,
Ooh, I think you're right.
And so it was this interesting thing
where you have this happening in Roxbury.
You also have happened in Philadelphia
that there's these shifts in urban areas
that sort of forcing
the American white Jews
out of these areas,
which is then basically then
leaving this black enclave.
And some of these black enclaves
are buying and purchasing on synagogues
and converting them into churches.
And so there's a lot of exchange here,
but something happens,
I think with the end
of black power, right,
where we see this kind
of explosion over Israel.
And then we have this period
between the 60s and the 80s.
When we see again, a rise of
black mayors and major cities,
you know, like Cleveland,
like Atlanta and DC
irony is that many of the
mayors, their campaign managers
were Jewish colleagues and friends, right.
Jesse Jackson, right?
Famous anti-Semitic comments
behind me town, you know,
his campaign manager was
an American-Jew, right.
Who was really interested
in trying to sort of
re galvanize the 60s.
And so we have this
moment between 60s and 70s
where blacks are occupying public spaces,
but there's a huge decline, right.
In terms of sort of black wealth.
And there's a kind of stagnancy there.
And there's also a sense in
which black mirrors are having
to appeal right, to the
business community, right.
Which is white Gentile and Jewish.
So there's crazy, really kind
of strange relationships,
right, again, you're dealing
with American-Jews, right.
Who, you know, there's
some kind of commonality,
but they're not in your community anymore.
Now they really are simply right.
The face behind a building quote unquote,
or your physician.
So it really changed the dynamics.
So I think for many of professional
American-Jews, you know,
they remember the stories right
around Abraham Heschel and King.
And then for African-Americans
between like the 70s
and 80s with the riser crack epidemic,
they don't see that, right.
They see great people
who have abandoned them.
And so the idea of having a
conversation it's not really
present now, will the leaders
have the conversation?
Oh yeah, when I call them the ministers,
oh, they're gladly have the conversation,
but the congregants are
like, well, I don't know,
what do we get out of this?
And so that's where my
culinary kind of stuck
in terms of how do we
get people on their own,
particularly in black churches, right.
Who want to have this conversation.
Now in terms of Black Lives Matter
what's interesting is a
number of the young advocates
were saying, look, we'll
talk to white Jews.
If they align with our political ideology
or we have some overlap,
let's have a conversation.
So I'm finding that's
where people interested in,
for galvanizing and informing
kind of coalitions, right.
Are in this sort of extensions
of Black Lives Matter, right.
Which has a very
interesting history as well.
So in some respects, you know,
even though I'm arguing for
a retrieval of the Exodus
the religious space, right.
Is not where it's necessarily happening,
but I still want to argue
that that language of Exodus
in terms of rethink dispossession, right.
A wilderness allows us
then to deal with sort of
contemporary issues
right around Palestine,
right around this idea of refugee crisis.
I think in galvanized both groups,
even though we're no longer in many cases
in the same communities
or worshiping together
or dining together in
the same social clubs.
- Okay, we're running out of time.
So I'm going to ask you
like two final questions
and you can kind of answer both either.
So one, you know, from the audience,
which picks up on something
that you've talked about
you know, 1967 as this turning point,
both because of the Black Power Movement
and also the six day war in Israel
at the beginning of the occupation.
And, you know, whether you
see like intersectionality,
for instance, now like an obstacle to,
I think a lot of Jews
see that as an obstacle
and how you know, think about that.
And then another question
about the nation of Islam.
So to what extent is your model predicated
on a kind of Jewish Christian dialogue
and how would you know, black
Muslims see that question
and see the whole Exodus model?
- No, both very good questions.
And I'll start with the,
I guess the hardest one
first is relation of Islam.
I mean, I would argue
that I see it as a kind of
a post-Christian kind of model, right.
In terms of really taking the Exodus story
outside of the confines
of sort of what it means
to have a sacred texts, sacred book,
and really using it in terms
of public deliberation, right.
Using the kind of images, right.
Not to reimagine a kind of exceptionalism
we're kind of chosen us, right.
But as a way to think
about in some respects,
those who are not very visible, right.
You know, in other words,
I'm trying to think of a model
of how then do we ignite even
those who are wealthy or
don't have wealth, right.
To see that they have a
shared interest in terms of,
if you believe in humanity, right.
And where some form of humanity
can we then agree upon,
right and we get to deal with issue
on refugee crisis, right.
Because it speaks to the
very depths of who we are
and what we think we imagine.
So in some respects, I
want to take out the excess
from the kind of religious sacred space
and look at it in terms of a kind of
working political vocabulary.
And, you know, intersectionality
is really interesting.
My colleague and I we're
really beginning to rest
with this now because I
look for Jewish Americans,
it's kind of in a basement, right.
It does not work.
And for African-Americans,
it becomes a way of recognizing right.
The multiplicities and differences, right.
In terms of with gender sexuality, right.
In class, that then allow us to see the,
kind of the nuances of anti-blackness.
And so intersectionality works for us.
And so now I think we need
to have comments in terms of
why isn't it working for American-Jews.
And I wonder is the question
around is what's is not working
that question of whiteness, right.
And in thinking through this idea
of really exploring sort of
the conception of whiteness
and the ways in which, you know,
some American-Jews are clean to that.
And really, I wanted to
bring into an bottom and say,
look, you know, do you
want to choose whiteness
or choose what it means
or just choose to be human
because whiteness is a kind
of social construction,
but it's a real culture construction.
When we think about the early
citizenship laws, right.
In order to, for the early immigrants
to gain citizenship, right.
In terms of a particular
salvation who came,
they answer no, we actually,
we're not black or white
we're part of the area, right.
So you have to include us as citizens.
So there was a real material good
to being white and historically.
And so I understand part of
that kind of their concern.
- Okay, well, you know,
we could really go on
all day or all night.
You have another talk you have to give,
and I know people have to go eat dinner
so we will stop it there and just say,
thank you so much,
Terrence, for that really,
really stimulating and really
just very smart dialogue.
So thank you very much.
I will clap on behalf of everyone else.
So thank you for coming.
- No, thank you for the invitation.
I had a great time, thank you.